or in New Orleans tonight the city at
the heart of the battle over preserving
American history and Confederate
monuments New Orleans has a the worst
murder rate and even worse than Chicago
today and more shootings per capita than
Baltimore if you can believe it and
Mayor Mitch Landrieu is on a crusade not
necessarily to stop crime but to hide
history these monuments celebrate a
fictional sanitised Confederacy ignoring
the death ignoring the enslavement
ignoring the terror that it actually
stood for and after the Civil War these
monuments were part of that terrorism as
much as burning across on someone's lawn
they were erected purposefully to send a
strong message to all who walked in the
shadows about who was still in charge in
this city now New Orleans took down 4
confederate statues last May after the
City Council declared them a public
nuisance there was no vote of the people
Landrieu called the effort a move toward
healing let's discuss statues the
mayor's priorities and what's next with
Malcolm Suber who is a coordinator with
the group group called take him down
NOLA and Thomas Bruno he's a board
member of the robert e lee monumental
association all right Malcolm let's
start with you so you must be pretty
happy that you took down four statues
you got Jeff Davis down Robert Ely is
down you got that Liberty monument down
and I'm Beauregard
general Beauregard you got him now he's
got four statues down markers down what
next for you well our name is taken down
NOLA and we want to take them all down
we there's more than 20 more statues
that are dedicated to white supremacy in
the city of New Orleans we have hundreds
of streets named and parks named for
Confederate and white supremacists and
so we want to wipe the slate clean and
we have challenged the mayor from the
very beginning don't do a half job let's
do the whole job if
really blow came out just sit here for a
second because Jackson Square is you
know that is New Orleans Jackson Square
do you square square to be the no it's
not okay Andrew Jackson to be eradicated
from New Orleans in the New Orleans
understand that to be so Jackson's down
okay let's move on would you like would
you like Thomas Jefferson anything
related to Thomas Jefferson George
Thomas Jefferson has to go straight
George Washington has to go okay who
else is left I got mad is Madison okay I
can't James Madison okay with you or no
he's not okay on the fence about him
he's not a slave okay okay so we need to
rename Washington DC correct yes I would
do that okay rename Washington DC got
for me to determine that's for the
people I was but that's what you want no
no we need to know we need to know
Malcolm we're really good things all
about we need to know where you're
coming from time for you to talk now
hold on to my friend we got it white
supremacy we got it let's go to Thomas
Thomas what's your sense on this well
Laura I thank you for having me first of
all and I would just like to say I love
the fact that Malcolm wants to allow
Washington disease DC to vote on the
name of the Capitol why didn't he allow
us have a vote in New Orleans on the
removal of the monuments the the mayor
the City Council decided for themselves
on this issue
let him speak please Malcolm Malcolm my
friend you must let the other guests
speak it is rude please let Thomas speak
thank you go ahead
okay so Malcolm says that these statues
represent white supremacy I'm not in a
position to tell Malcolm what he should
think about these statues these are
pieces of art folks are free to make
their own interpretation of what they
mean or don't mean there are a variety
of different ways of looking at these
pieces for him to say that these are
this way and that anyone who disagrees
with that is wrong to me is absurd these
are pieces of art they're created in
in a matter in which their multiplicity
of ways of looking at them and when
historians look at these pieces of art
they have a variety of different ways of
interpreting them when I've been around
these pieces of art all of my life and
it never occurred to me for one second
that they were symbols of white surprise
mitch landrieu himself said when Wynton
challenged him to take down those
statues Mitch said we talking about
Wynton I don't know I know what you mean
but these statutes mean white supremacy
the reason that Mitch did not understand
this because a lot of folks in this city
do not see the statues that way okay
let's go to back to Malcolm Malcolm a
lot offensive to black people and when
the black until the last so I don't know
what two or three years and I'm coming
in New Orleans on and off for the last
20 years until the last about two years
I hadn't heard anyone talk about the
statues in Charlottesville in the
Worland in New York until mostly outside
agitators came in and said guess what
history has to be eradicated we have to
rename every federal building we have to
completely change history in context and
we have to get rid of it all I see
groups had never heard it this is the
this is the fundamental problem because
what's happening in our city is that one
group of people is deciding for everyone
else how we should think about a piece
of art with black people and they put
them up without any input whatsoever
from the black mt and now that we are at
least majority it is up to us to decide
what I completely agree Malcolm Malcolm
you were not going to believe this but I
agree with you it's up to the people to
decide and if the people decide they
want to remove the monuments that's that
that's the will of the people then Ram
through at night and remove the statues
and put them in a place we don't even
know where those statues are as far as I
could we don't know it's right Thomas
yes we don't know what's going to one of
the things that is so shocking about the
whole process is that the City Council
and the mayor never had any plan in
place for what happened to the monuments
well I didn't care for history as well
Malcolm have you back have you on radio
both of you were great thank you so much